to get to what we thought about the show
in general yes exactly General King is
about to say his peace
so uh who's gonna go first we're going
to let our guests go first yeah let's go
let's go guess
it's quiet
for holding down the tech aspects behind
the scenes we appreciate you brother
yeah I was trying my best not to screw
this up I was like you did a great job
bro fantastic job thank you thank you
overall man um uh great show great show
it was um if I have to I'm probably not
I'm dying to watch this thing on demand
at 4K 60.
um but based off the immediate reactions
I'm going to say eight and a half
um uh 8.5 and I'll just start with the
things I uh I guess I was I guess
dissatisfied with one thing I was
dissatisfied with was the uh the lack of
uh Combat gameplay for hellblade to
um
which is I mean the game looks good we
already know that every time they've
shown in-game I believe that's what the
game's gonna look like it's it's fine
but I was hoping they just like you know
breaking like a enemy and and show us
what we're gonna be doing
um and then this is disappointing for a
different reason this is more so my
expectations I was hoping just hoping
hellblade to will sneak in to this year
this year to close out the year with you
know star film reports so that was more
so like a sort of a a letdown but
and the other thing is during the
Starfield gameplay which I was you know
like feel really really focused that's
where I was quiet because they were
talking they were letting hints drop and
every time the the lead tech or the
designer or the combat dude I went to
see all right are they going to reveal
its performance and they did not clarify
uh the performance mode for consoles
um for Starfield maybe it comes in the
next coming days but I was hoping that
but other than that man overall they
open strong which I did not anticipate
them to open with Fable I figured they
maybe you know close with it but that
thing started looking like another a
form
Hogwarts Legacy as far as graphically
I'm like oh this is Fable
um uh I think that showed off well they
started the show very like very strong
and they kept it they kept up the
momentum they didn't have too many of
those uh I remember that showcase I
watched you guys a couple years ago and
it did the King was like give that Keely
there was not too many of those there
like and I'm like okay so and the fact
that when Hellboy came in I was like all
right they did I was like hell play
they're not closing with hellblade they
didn't close with evolved but they both
showed up and they both showed up in a
big way
um and I'm excited to again rewatched it
because we were watching the 1080p
twitch stream I don't really like the
quality of twitch but I kept dancing
over to the side because it was playing
also on my TV at 4K I'm like oh wow oh
it's crazy and it looks crazy so
um the only thing is is that uh
next year you know pretty much Xbox
their first part they're coming in hard
like I'm happy to see compulsion finally
reveal their game uh with the south of
the south of the midnight I think it was
called uh south of midnight yeah yeah
and um in Exile with their steampunk RPG
uh uh that one is called the the clock
Clockwork Revolution that that looks
like that leg's Gonna Make some noise
and um it's happy to I'm happy to hear
and see from the Xbox Studios and then
you start thinking about the studios
that you didn't hear from and then um
the only thing again that makes it like
kind of ho-hum is
the fact that all right for the rest of
the year it's really like the Starfield
and Forza which essentially has to blow
our our socks off when we get in our
hands uh to close out the air and that's
really the disappointing part it's like
it's just it's not that they're bad
games it's like I think they need at
least one more game uh to send off the
year because when you consider star
field and Forza we've known these games
were supposed to come out years prior if
you think about it right so um that's
where it becomes disappointing but
overall the Showcase
um best showcase easily of the summer
um so far what we had in my opinion
um I've all the games that were shown at
this uh event looked great and I have
interest in
um and a lot of the games that a lot of
games I anticipate have now been
displayed at this uh showcase so they
did a wonderful job there though I
thought they started strong ended strong
start I and I'm I'm not the biggest fan
of Bethesda game studios is hard selling
you on these long drawn out RPGs but
they sold me on Starfield I will be
eager to try and try to get invested in
that game
that's what's up
you're already doing what it is baby
first of all I'm gonna say it's a 10 out
of 10. I've seen every I've seen and and
let me say this I told people on a few
podcasts last week people said oh this
has to kill Sony show no no no
this show has to be good for us as Xbox
fans that's not to do it no other
company I don't care what the mother
shows did I don't care what games they
didn't show I wanted to see the money
that y'all invested in these companies
come to fruition I needed to see first
party bangers I wanted to see all the
stuff that we fantasize about oh I need
ever Wows I need a valve I need this I
need that and they gave you exactly from
the beginning to the end they gave you
every single game games that may go into
2024 but we got to see gameplay
everybody was begging for fable out the
door slam dunk game is over they didn't
play no games and that's what I wanted
to see I wanted to see what you have
forget the third party partners because
those games is everywhere show me why I
invested 542 dollars in the console day
one yeah and they did that and they did
that that's the only thing that's the
only thing I wanted and then they hit us
with other bangers we didn't even know
what's coming
Phil said
I will show you games you will see games
that you've never even heard before we
got that
Starfield
oh we don't know what it is just that
the third the the the the the walk
through we got that nobody if you wanted
60 or 30 I'm telling you it's gonna be
30. just leave it but you ain't gonna
say well I'm not playing it especially
after that showcase everybody on board
now anybody got rid of the Xbox was
coming right back
be right back what else could you
possibly ask everybody right yo listen
what what could you ask for you want a
gameplay you got it you wanted details
you got it they gave you everything
everybody in the chat I'm watching the
chat everybody has lit nobody was like
man that game's not my feet no
it's got white houses 200 people
watching let's get those likes over a
thousand let's go straight bangs almost
there let's go
did you cry man tears is the question
what did you cry
oh I I I liked it I thought it was like
a solid experience I was really
disappointed with the lack of uh hell
Play 2 gameplay yeah
moves at the same thing
all right all right that's it all right
so yeah so what I'm saying is after we
we really we we really needed that right
because yeah let's not let's be real
here our morale was down
everything banked on this show we had a
bad few months you know what I'm saying
so we really needed this and as as
Gamers we're excited to see great stuff
but when you when you say this is an
Xbox showcase we want to see Xbox stuff
yeah so that to me I agree 100 man it is
to me they needed to show if you think
about it they showed the games from
first party that we didn't know what
they were exactly right they sold
compulsions game they showed obviously I
talked about about whatever
um everything else we kind of know what
it is we know what Perfect Dark is we
know there's other stuff in the pipeline
there are some Stills obviously some
Secrets out there still but to me this
was the fact that it was Xbox first
party after Xbox first party after Xbox
first party I was like I was I was
watching it in the car while driving in
I'm like damn it's one after the other
one after the other I was like yo they
really they're doing it
and then obviously the things that would
have really really popped besides the
first party stuff that kind of got
leaked the Persona stuff that would have
been huge and the fact that it's going
into game pass that would have been ten
times more both of them both both of
them that that is Bonkers to me I gotta
that I almost I almost willing to give
up my knees over that even though it's
not personally six because it's going in
the game pass that is something else and
Persona 3 is beloved beloved because it
is the start of that formula that
everybody loves with persona 5. persona
3 kind of really started that so um for
that to come back and be a Game Pass is
a special thing man and they showed out
even with the third party stuff they
show that the Star Wars you know I'm a
little funny sometimes about their you
know first party third party stuff and
what I expect to be mostly first party
stuff but the Star Wars was crazy you
want to see more of it at Ubisoft
forward tomorrow
cool
um but everything from first party and
like 108 alluded to it's all all of it
looks great and all of it is varied
you're not seeing you're not you're not
seeing everything kind of looking the
same and stuff like that and I get it
that third person over the shoulder
that's what we consider Banger Hellboy
is going to be there and I totally agree
with smooth on the fact that man I
really wanted to see that combat because
to me the combat is where that game is
going to live and die because everything
else
the story stuff the stuff with the with
the with the multiple personalities and
the voices talking to her we know they
can get that right I I know the fields
are gonna be there but the combat in the
first one was very basic whatever but
they but but a Ninja Theory is very good
with combat they have always been there
so I really want to see them step it up
with that and really make this into an
action game they can gravitate to a lot
of people but I was super impressed and
again I've had my reservations about
Starfield
because for me it's just one of those
things where it's like man I don't want
to be a vast ocean that's ankle deep
right right what we saw today was not
that nice there are aspects of it that
again we talked about the faces we
talked about this then the other way
when you're creating a game of this
scope you're gonna have to have some
concessions it's just a fact like the
real console game could really do that
and be get there
um and uh to be perfectly honest there's
no better team than Todd's team to be
able to realize that type of vision
um so I'm excited to play it man I'm
excited to play it I have a feeling we
talked about this I think last week
about what they talk about the frame
rate here whatever if it was 16 they
would have mentioned it so I don't think
it's 60. but listen he came out and said
listen I like 30 frames yeah
the community keep pushing them listen
he says I like 30 frames and you know
what I was impressed about this morning
right it's his creative it's his
creative thing
but this this was crazy
they showed what what they really show
and displayed to everybody that your
investment into Game Pass is even more
it's warranted it's going crazy oh the
Capricorn game the yo the Capcom game
looks awesome again something new again
sometimes you think about hey man they
can't get Resident Evil whatever they
got a new Capcom IP to be shown first on
their on their stage
and it because it shows Above All Else
and in the atlas Sega thing also it just
shows that the relationship is there the
the the what you would call it the path
to these conversations about certain
games that PlayStation always gets first
things of that nature all of those
conversations are continuing to happen
and again as game pass grows the reason
to put these games onto Game Pass and
Xbox period continues to be more
compelling so for me they really really
really showed out today I'm so happy
today
but yeah I I didn't I didn't see the
number six though
because that game passed that game pass
was real I like I'll give you a half
beneath for that I appreciate it
the battle still rages the battle rages
on
it was something else so let's before we
go to to to the king General King let's
see what the laws that were in the
building have to say let's go it ain't
different in here man like you already
see the energy was super high the way
they set it off with Fable fables look
crazy to me like that joint graphically
like
listen write down overall I'm debating
between the eight and the nine I got a
little bit [__] only because
the game look the show was amazing let's
just get that off the way they killed
that right now it's about how great was
it my only nitpick was hellblade I was
hoping for some some combat yeah
so I gotta did pick a little bit that
and then there was a couple of this is I
don't know compulsion Choice look good
but like there's a little instance I was
like I got to see a little bit more from
you but I will say in Exile yeah I look
crazy they showed out on third part they
showed out on Indies but I think it's
over with what the hell song I feel this
now I think we could put that the rest
with oh yeah
you know what it is
yeah
the only thing you could say is if yeah
they say it was 30 or 60.30 energy but I
don't get did you see what you can do
with this game yeah yeah
it's crazy bro so for me
right now I'm in that 8.5 kind of Zone
Starfield I won't say this off
at first I was disappointed that the one
more thing wasn't Starfield Starfield
another game another game in the main
show as if they was nervous
because that's what you're gonna think
about it they show the game for the
people that's not gonna watch Starfield
right it was like they wouldn't probably
nervous that people wouldn't stay for
the direct so you got to give them a
little something a little something I
will say even though I was disappointed
at first that the one more thing wasn't
a new game how they showed out with
Starfield was so ridiculous yeah it was
so insane I was like nah they did and
we're getting that this year and I was
like they did that you can't combat
everything look good again the only
thing you would say is whether or not
it's performance mode or not it don't
feel like it's going to be but I will
say I don't care that game
for me yo and a vowed bro oh wow what
crazy but yeah the energy crazy in here
man everybody out here showing out bro
the building the roof was crazy I'm
telling y'all man but I heard to hold
the line stuff was crazy over there
crowd move
moving the line crazy so King I need the
channel where you at
well
live from the battlefield we heard the
opposition brought a knife to a gunfight
and Microsoft brought bazookas
[Laughter]
for British today is what I want to know
it was like British accent today
okay
oh you yellow belly fat stuck into that
ran away
I told you
June 11th it was D-Day for you pause
[Music]
[Laughter]
you got Banger after Banger first part
we believe in Generations here
we believe in first party studios here
we have the best and the brightest
at no point in time did you see TV
did you see a movie trailer
racing game it was actual cars in a
racing game
Listen People you have been repping the
wrong people
over here at Xbox we'll take you in
that's right it'll go nice with your
Miles Morales Spider-Man
we believe in ssds over here
all the stuff that we say is actual
factual so we shout out with the show I
got to get a show 9.5
I gotta deduct the five uh for uh
hellblade not showing uh actually no
combat I feel you that's it I feel you
Jennifer they did they did not talk they
walked the walk
she said at this point in time I would
like you to take your wallet Fold It Up
and mail it to Aruba
because your wallet is going on vacation
all day bangers yeah it was like they
went through the building it was like
who got games to present
is done
fight is over I told y'all to hold the
line shout out to everybody that's
holding the line everybody that went and
held the line
go to Teespring store today if you're a
PlayStation dude in your recovery
but the war has won
the show was terrible we welcome you
over here so General
on the neck energy what's the energy
it's Crocs on the neck energy and cracks
on the neck energy
we got combat cracks
it's a combat apparel
we was ready for that war you worry
you came in with a knife
we had the blicky yeah
I told you
heavyweight champ yeah they did that
defeated they did that
Microsoft I told you this is the rise of
Dolph film
this is the day that we go down
this is the day when you see there's no
going back to the old ways
on the show
I gotta ask like how did you feel to
create a whole movement where people
believe again and they back in line
listen man because you know what it is
sometimes you need to see that light in
the darkness and you know I had to roll
out and I said Megatron Must Be Stopped
no matter what the cost
stop right now they ain't looking the
same the dance is weak and they ain't
got no games
this year and next year we sold it up
so real quick question
um were you doing ratings yet
yes sir I rated it a 9.5 I'm giving it
8.5
Square too
but besides that it
you know some of the
indie games that really apply to me but
I saw how white some people would find
them appealing
I know they picked a good news yeah you
know people don't mind seeing Indies at
showcases they want to see it needs that
look appealing to a lot of people and I
feel like they did that
very well let's get Wolverine I have to
get 8.5
yeah yeah am I right where we got baby I
gave it a 10.
I would like to see it but I'm not
taking no points for that because the
whole show was amazing we only seen two
people for two minutes right that's what
games games games games games for Xbox
Xbox
yo it was crazy
we got dates Capcom bend the knee
we got other companies I mean what can
you say really yeah we probably I'm
probably out of nine I gotta watch the
whole thing over again because for me I
was watching it in the car driving yeah
thank you beautiful 1K likes in one show
we still got a thousand plus people
watching every last one of you as we
wrap up this show because we not doing
four hours
so so for me nine so far and I again I I
was watching it all in in the car
watching it all the way up until the
Fallout 76 stuff and then that's when I
arrived I had to leave and get upstairs
or whatever right so so that's I because
I felt kind of like the energy might be
going down a little bit because it was
starting to show the the things that had
the show right yeah so I feel like the
live Services look at like unless you
have giant expansions I feel like to see
if these ones a little bit made more
sense because that was that made 100
sense yeah yeah it was though
from long distance I don't know I don't
know
shoulders
show them the door we will leave and I
will put the podcast
no so you'll get my final score next
4K 60 in a little while I want to see
that in its entirety yeah yeah okay
he left after the Showcase
JW had to go man he had to go man
um
wait a minute I need to see gameplay of
that that Star Wars game
later he had to get out the house
because I said in the Repo Man over
there for his knee
my man
I send the Repo Man over there to get
his knees so he had to get up out the
house one thing I will say about fables
is it does look like they have a good
comment like they met me in the middle
grade that playground engine it looks
like they're doing a lot of humor but
it's like less crazy ways than they did
in the previous one oh that's okay
that's crazy see y'all later all right
we'll listen to your Tweet
yeah that's it we we that's it that is
our initial impression so next week
we'll probably talk about it more in
depth especially if any more news comes
out in the Xbox extended showcase right
we're gonna have some more stuff going
on uh tomorrow we have Ubisoft as well
so maybe some more Xbox Centric stuff I
had hoped to see Splinter Cell
you know what they did they did 12
months without telling you 12 months bro
kind of connoissota right they did 12
months without telling you 12 months
they they said you know what we ain't
gonna say it no more we're just gonna do
it yeah you realize that it you just you
just set up a rake for yourself when you
don't do it saying things just do yeah
and then obviously the dates will speak
for themselves